[Musik]
meine lieben freunde herzlich willkommen
wie heute zu einer weiteren episode
minecraft mit luca staffel 2 ihr seht
bereits den titel wir gehen auf reisen
heute steht die große erkundung an mein
limit
heute steht der große kundus folge an
meine lieben freunde nichts wird heute
vor mir sicher sein ich werde ein
bisschen meine welt erkunden und dafür
nehme ich mir auch direkt schon so ein
paar sachen mit wie beispielsweise dass
ich mir erstmal ganz kurz der neue
schaufel mache dann meine hier ist fast
kaputt deswegen können wir die beiden
dann ganz fix eben kombinieren damit wir
keinen platz verschwenden ich werde den
großteil des kupfers hier lassen und
auch den großteil meines eisens und mir
nur noch ein bisschen kohle mitnehmen so
dass ich mir wenn ich bock habe 109 exil
[Musik]
das ist doch nicht wahr
alter das ist wirklich nicht wahr
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob ich den angeguckt habe
der krieg hat schild einfach nach vorn
an unserer base ich bin noch mal ganz
kurz hier eben zu den süßen und nehme
hier ein bisschen was mit so dass ich
ein
[Musik]
ist die hürde
dieses scheiß süß wehrleiter wie soll
ich die denn eher lohnen die teile
reinzulaufen um die teile aufzunehmen
hieß
schon wieder alles hier auf ihr vorne
hole ich mir auch noch mal ganz kurz die
bären da muss ich allerdings einen fix
herumlaufen um die auf sammeln zu können
und dann sind wir jetzt eigentlich auch
schon fertig für unsere kunden meiner
lieben freunde der ein oder andere der
von euch natürlich selbstständig
abonnent von einem kanal ist und auch
die glocke aktiviert hat der wird es
mitbekommen haben und zwar habe ich euch
vor zwei stunden gefragt ob ihr wollt
dass ich in diese richtung laufen oder
wieder zurück in richtung spawn zum
sumpf auch das krokodil war und ihr seht
hier bereits die umfrage eingeblendet
das sind nämlich die ergebnisse die ich
vorhin mal die screenshot habe und da
hat sich ziemlich klar herausgestellt
dass die meisten leute wollten dass ich
mich zurück in richtung spawn bewege
deswegen würde ich sagen sprinten wir
darin jetzt zurück ich hätte zwar auch
bock sich in diese richtung hier vorne
zu bewegen und einfach mal zu schauen wo
es uns hier vorne hin verschlägt er sich
ein riesiger schnee bio im riesiger wald
ich bin auch gespannt was da hinten ist
denn da vorne fand ich ja auch ganz
schön da könnte ich mir auch vorstellen
hin zu ziehen allerdings will ich
erstmal machen dass ich erst mal bevor
ich mich wirklich niederlassen und jetzt
hier irgendwie so pläne nachgehe wie das
wird mir noch geschrieben luca baum eine
windmühle mit einem fetten feld dran und
so bevor ich mich solchen kleben ich
widme habe ich mir gesagt ich will hier
erst mal alles so ein bisschen erkunden
und wirklich dann auch zu checken okay
da will ich auch bleiben was ist das
habe
die sache ist halt dass ich es hier
extrem schön finde richtig süß sie mit
dem kleinen fluss und so
unter van riet mich richtig auf deswegen
fliege ich jetzt auch weg
immer wieder ein vergnügen messbar aber
ich finde es ja auf jeden fall überall
ziemlich schön hier haben wir einige
fische und ich könnte auch vor ständig
gefordert diese kleine insel zu bauen
oder hier vorne auf diese landzunge
zwischen dem fluss und dem meer hier
vorne also wir haben auf jeden fall
einige orte die ich sehr sehr feiert
allerdings möchte ich halt bevor ich
mich richtig niederlasse erstmal alles
ein bisschen erkunden
entweder die waschbären noch ja ist gut
dort sind die laut wo ich noch zu beginn
dachte dass das in welche stinktiere
sind und ich mich dann darauf aufmerksam
machte dass dass ich mich hier auch
schon lese echt viele bälle naja hab
mich ja darauf aufmerksam macht dass das
eher stinktiere waschbären sind noch
keine spur
ich hab ein fortschritt dafür bekommen
dass ein vogel auf mich zugeflogen ist
gut wir lassen uns hier gar nicht lang
ablenkt meine lieben freunde ihr habt
entschieden
ich soll mich in richtung sport bewegen
und da glaube ich auch dir action hin
ich habe leider keine karte am start
oder irgendwas
weshalb ich leider mich komplett auf die
minimap verlassen muss karte konnte ich
mir da denn ich mache dafür benötigt man
red und ich habe in meiner höhen
expedition folge gestern leider kein
redstone gefunden deswegen klappt das
leider nicht die sache ist allerdings
ich komme mit
will ich aber eigentlich nicht ist mir
scheißegal
na gut dann kommt der rabe halten mit
auf reisen ich habe leider kein brett er
fliegt doch schon vor perfekte lauf man
direkt hinterher ich habe leider keinen
gefunden deswegen müssen uns jetzt ein
bisschen auf die minimal verlassen ist
allerdings nicht weiter schlimm denn ich
habe die minimap auch ein bisschen
upgraded wir wurden nämlich in die
kommentare geschrieben luca es gibt eine
möglichkeit dass du bei der minimap
einfach auswählen kann stay bitte freue
mich nicht dass das nur die sachen oben
rechts angezeigt werden die ich wirklich
schon entdeckt habe die sache ist
allerdings was ich diese funktion ich
gefunden habe
ich habe sie allerdings dahingehend gab
gerettet dass ich ich kann ich mal
sprinten
ich brauche
unglaublich auf dauert wenn es deutlich
geiler das map oben rechts jetzt
quadratisch ist weil das dann alles auch
symmetrischer ist wenn ich kommentare
ein denn und das sieht doch einfach
geiler aus
wir sind schon angekommen
und ich habe immer noch schiff
und diesen dummen krokodilen hier
und man weiß ja auch gar nicht wo die wo
die herkommen weil hier alles so
verwachsen ist und so
[Musik]
ich will halt nach da hinten und mal
kurz auf den berg darauf immer zu gucken
was da vorne so abgeht aber hier sind
halt überall
krokodile
aber gut wir haben keine andere wahl
freunde wir müssen durch den sumpf durch
sonst müssen wir einen riesigen umweg
laufen wenn er einfach mal hoffen dass
uns kein krokodil hier unter die finger
gerät ich werde jetzt auch einfach mal
in der 5 modus wechseln so dass wir so
ein bisschen mehr um uns rum gucken
können aber bisher klappt alles
eigentlich wunderbar also kein krokodil
es uns bisher begegnet vielleicht
spawnen die auch erst wenn wir uns
wirklich in den bio befinden von daher
werde ich jetzt einfach mal so ein
bisschen drüber jumpen jetzt bin ich
hier relativ offen
wenn irgendein krokodil von der seite
kommt nicht raste aus
sie hat wahrscheinlich eine halbe
herzinfarkt kriegen aber gut wir haben
schon fast geschafft meine lieben
freunde hier vorne ist dieses komische
portal dingen was wir auch damals
unserem stronghold in minecraft mit luca
staffel eins gefunden haben und wir
haben hier vielleicht auch wieder eine
kiste wo dinge drin sind um
die dirne feuerkugel vorstellen und
explosionsschutz
das komplette genom gewandert ist ich
werde jetzt auch einfach mal die kiste
hier mitnehmen da habe ich nämlich keine
vom mitgenommen falls nämlich hier
irgend ein bisschen länger bleiben kann
ich da noch ein paar sachen reinpacken
mehr dinge haben wir hier allerdings
nicht wir haben da oben noch gold blöcke
da könnte ich mich mal ich hab auch
keine späne mitgenommen ich idiot da
könnte ich mich eben kurz mit meinem
holz und es den hochbau und gold blöcke
sind ja sehr sehr geil die können wir
auch später für straighten ganz benutzen
hier haben wir auch ran und da können
wir uns direkt so ein bisschen hoch
klettern und dann bauen wir jetzt den
blog ich einfach mal ab und den hier
vorne es sieht schon sehr sehr gut
[Musik]
was ist das
honig saugen
kein plan
ich dachte es wäre jetzt irgendwie sowie
fox von harry potter oder wie
klug oder so bei pokemon oder so das ist
irgendwie so ein phönix eving sondern so
ein tier oder keine ahnung was da so
rumpf und was total selten ist aber
honig saugen hört sich jetzt nicht so
selten an
[Musik]
architekt
nummer idiot
mein gott ich hatte mein leben hier
vorne steht allerdings ein schaf auf dem
baum bzw auf dem berg wo ist denn jetzt
hin gelaufen ich vorne war der vorderen
scharf irgendwo hab keine ahnung auf
jeden fall muss ich mir auf jeden fall
erstmal eine neue schere machen man kann
ja mal schauen ob wir hier irgendwo das
schaf wiederfinden die sache ist ich
gucke auch die ganze zeit hier so
komisch mit zugekniffenen augen
[Musik]
er ist geschichte aber das schaffen
da es ist ich habe ja die helligkeit von
meinem das hat wie viele habe ich drei
mein gott walter habe ich glück oh mein
gott das kannst wieder nicht ausdenken
ich habe die helligkeit von meinem
bildschirm runter gestellt dass es für
mich selbst schwieriger ist hierbei
nacht irgendwie was zu finden oder
irgendwie mich zurechtzufinden das ist
zwar total dumm und kontraproduktiv
allerdings dachte ich mir dass das ein
bisschen challenge mäßiger ist mein gott
aber was habe ich denn für ein glück
dass mir das schafft genau drei wolle
gegeben hat perfekt fürs bett also wir
können auf jeden fall schlafengehen
meine lieben freunde und die nacht
überspringen ich muss erst mal wieder
hereinkommen diese ganzen minecraft
sache ich weiß ich habe nur wie lange
habe ich pause gemacht drei wochen zwei
wochen oder so nach minecraft staffel
eins nach vorne rennen skelette
allerdings zum glück hat das geklappt
ich baue mir hier direkten baum ab und
hoffe dass ich hier einen reichen
setzlingen bekomme denn ich habe einfach
bei mir in der truhe kleinen setzlingen
und ich habe eigentlich mir überlegt für
meine pace da unten etwas mit eichen zu
bauen und musste dann auch fichtenholz
ein bisschen ausweichen bei der einen
oder anderen situation deswegen werde
ich jetzt erstmal die bäume so ein
bisschen abbauen damit ich ihnen
möglichkeiten
für weitere künftige
modellprojekte die ich irgendwie bauen
möchte dir vorne und die birke bauen wir
noch mal eben ab und dann hat sich auch
hier alles direkt entfernt das ist ja
das geile an unserer tritscher
modifikation denn jetzt auch auf jeden
fall zwölf eichen setzlinge und vier
birken setzlinge das sollte
[Musik]
ich die worte direkt wieder mit wir
bewegen uns jetzt allerdings mal hier
auf den berg drauf denn das ist auch so
ein bisschen das ziel für die heutige
wiese oder den habe ich ja schon ein
bisschen kollege vor in der ersten folge
von dieser minecraft mit luca staffel 2
habe ich ja schon von dort hinten von
unserem spawn aus diesen riesigen berg
hier entdeckt deswegen ist es mein ziel
für heute gewesen eigentlich einfach mal
zurück zu laufen es durch diesen sumpf
zu schaffen ich weiß nicht ob ihr
irgendwo ein krokodil seht ich sehe kein
es vielleicht gibt es auch wirklich in
jedem sumpf nur dieses eine krokodil das
war er bei mir dort hinten allerdings
war es mein ziel hier hoch zu kommen das
habe ich auf jeden fall geschafft jetzt
schon lange hier
du kannst auch fliegende idiot natürlich
bist du schneller gewesen na gut meine
lieben freunde wie können wir schauen
was da vorne ist wenn da ich das hier
aber sind das die ganz normale tatsachen
kommen mit ganz normal weiter raus oder
sind dass irgendwelche anderen sachen
hier kommen ganz normale weizenkörner
raus okay das ist nichts besonderes was
[Musik]
na ja so ein scheiß knapp am cut das
krasse ist wenn ich hier so lange laufen
würde würde ich mir denken ich bin auf
höhe keine ahnung was ist normale
minecraft für 60 70 so um den dreh aber
ich
[Musik]
hasse ziegen ich war mal im streichelzoo
nein er hat mir den komisches rohren
gegen das schimmern gehauen das waren
meine tante
und du hattest das auch verdient
gut zu wissen da oben haben wir noch ein
bisschen kohle und was wir generell hier
auch direkt sehen ist das hier auch
einfach so bruchsteine sind so ein
bisschen bemoosten steinen kies ganz
normale steine also alles so ein
bisschen durcheinander
wir haben hier unten schweine ganz
komische wieder blüten oder so und
halten noch ein paar mehr ziehen die
allerdings bei ich erst mal ganz kurz
die kohle ab und ich finde es wirklich
extrem geil dass wir diese bei uns ob
plenty modifikation heute beziehen wir
generell in der micro karstadt für zwei
jahre mit am start haben und so dass wir
einfach weiß ich nicht wie viele biome
haben wir zu viele verschiedene regionen
in minecraft blogger irgendwie 20.30
also es gibt so viel noch zu entdecken
und auch dieses bio mir gerade bin ich
wirklich extrem schön die kohle haben
wir auf jeden fall als erstmal abgebaut
ich bewege mich erst mal so ein bisschen
weiter hier in die richtung mehr wir auf
jeden fall eine riesige berglandschaft
und es fühlt sich wirklich so an als
wenn wir ganz normal auf 460 oder so
aber wir sind wahrscheinlich auch 100
oder 120 oder so hier
ist er habe noch ein paar schafe er ist
ohne stress ich das letzte mal runter
laufen müssen und dann wieder hoch oder
so wir berichten sie seien oder sowas
und da sind wir auch schon auf der
anderen seite angekommen wohin man auch
hier vorne jetzt mir hier davor und das
komische kag stifter da stand ich gerne
mal eben kurz die schafe das hat mir
meine kräfte luca staffel eins immer so
ein bisschen gefehlt am ende mit diesen
ganzen wolle sachen oder so dann muss
ich da auch seide um weichen und dann
kam das dann irgendwie ein
kleines mini schafft mir geht's in die
höhle und
nur ein kleiner natürlicher tunnel wir
schauen wo es hingeht das schaf hat sich
direkt wieder passen geschäft mein gott
das ist ja ein tor ist geil aus
er schaut euch das mal an auf der
minimap ist sieht so aus als wäre das
hier wirklich das schön ein paar fliegen
direkt
als wäre hühner haben wir auch am start
es sieht so aus als wäre das hier vorne
also jetzt anhand der minimap auch oben
recht wenn ihr dabei hinschaut als wir
das einfach sonnenberg vorsprung hier
[Musik]
und wir können dann hier über alles
drüber gucken
dass
[Musik]
lassen delfin
ja das ist ein delfin wir sind thunfisch
[Musik]
ich
bin ein bisschen sprachlos gerade bin
ich ganz ehrlich das ist ja die erste
richtige erkundungs folge und ich
entdeckt gerade so ein paar neue biome
die diese modifikation halt nun mal dazu
bringt wie beispielsweise halt diese
komischen berge wo wir gerade waren der
sumpf mit den krokodilen und jetzt
anscheinend irgendwie einen kürbis
landschaft oder so
[Musik]
es sind ganz normale kürbisse
katholischen ruckelt
das ist nämlich auch das ding nicht
jeder kann mir dieser bei uns oppland
die modifikation spiele ich habe schon
viele kommentare bekommen von leuten
lukrativen das sogar bei dem ihr den
ganzen bio mit den monstern wenn ich das
bei mir installiere dann harkt alles uns
so ja das ist halt ein bisschen
schwierig mit dieser modifikation das
beansprucht den pc wirklich enorm weil
halt so viele neue sachen zu gefährden
da guck mal wie schön das hier alles
aussieht
ja sogar beleuchtet nach vorne
es ist schon richtig herbstliche und
auch leicht halloween angehauchte
landschaft hier gerade das ist wirklich
sehr sehr geil hier vorne die sonne
neigt sich dem ende zu mit ihm freuen
ich würde sagen dass ich an der stelle
dann auch die heutigen episode minecraft
mit luca beenden würde ich brauche jetzt
ein paar kürbisse mal abgelöst da kann
man ja immer gebrauchen ich keine ahnung
wofür aber
ja keine ahnung firma küste geborgen
damit das sieht wirklich sehr sehr sehr
sehr schön aus bei nacht ein bisschen
furchteinflößend aber das haben
natürlich auch so sachen ansicht
deswegen nicht passieren weil mädchen
jetzt einfach mal hier vorne leg mich
kennen und würde an der stelle die
heutige episode minecraft mit luca die
erste große erkundungs folge und auch
beendet meine lieben freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat dann lass gern einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier da
abonniert main kanal und klickt auf die
glocke wenn ihr neue videos minecraft
mit luca nicht verpassen wollt wir sehen
uns nicht morgen wieder denn morgen
kommt um 18 uhr eine neue episode tik
tok tuesday endlich mal wieder wir
werden uns nämlich übermorgen wieder bei
minecraft mit luca und ihr könnt mir
jetzt unten kommentare schreiben was ich
machen soll oder in ihr zu unkreativ
seid dann schaut einfach mal in die
kommentare denn da sind zwei kommentare
von mir selber geschrieben worden
erstens ein kommentar ob ich in der
nächsten folge mich in richtung schnee
biom bewegen soll 100 komplett durch
mein studium durchlaufen soll war schon
so dass ich in die richtung so befindet
oder kommentar nummer zwei ob ich mich
ringsrum um meine keller base ein
bisschen umschauen soll also leicht
entweder in meinen einen kommentar oder
einen anderen kommentar dementsprechend
was ihr wollt was in der nächsten
episode minecraft und locker machen soll
und dann sehen wir uns übermorgen wieder
die luft entscheiden wir sehen uns
[Musik]